hello guys my name is channel welcome to
episode 11 of the serialization series
so we're gonna be jumping into databases
today and figuring out how we can
actually bundle all these arrays and
objects together into some kind of a
larger system so that we can just shove
that data into a file and then later
recall it as necessary so last time
yeah we've kind of finished off our
objects and arrays and fields and
everything was working pretty well we
also managed to print everything out
into a file and see all the lovely stuff
here that's great okay the last step
here before we get into like
optimization or anything like that is to
create some kind of database that can
hold multiple objects and multiple
arrays right I mean I did kind of say
that like in terms of container types we
do kind of have all these ones right
database is kind of the higher level one
right database is the one that holds
them all so the idea is right now we
have like the perfect ability to
actually send off objects and we can
actually send multiple objects into a
stream of bytes there's nothing
preventing us from doing that if I kind
of copy and paste this and pull this
object one or something like that and
call it literally object one and then I
kind of just say object one don't get
byte stream suddenly you know I'll have
to adjust the the stream here to make
sure that I also have whoops that I also
have enough size for you know the the
other object but the idea is you can see
that I kinda can actually kind of
concatenate to two objects together in a
row and have them exist inside this byte
stream that's fine that's not really an
elegant way to do this because first of
all it means you have to know how many
objects are in here like for example if
I wanted then
recall those objects I could obviously
just easily say that I know that there
are two objects
I need the size of each of the objects
which I do have so I could kind of
rejoin them but I don't know what's in
the byte stream especially if I'm kind
of reading this from client side so
that's obviously a terrible way to do it
and it's not something that we really
want to do I just wanted to show you
that it is in fact kind of possible
right now there's nothing stopping us
from actually literally just appending
all of these objects arrays fields
whatever into one big blob of data but
that's not how we want to do it we want
to obviously be structured and organized
and all that stuff so the first thing
we'll do is we'll make a class and I'll
call this our C database okay we're
gonna kind of take inspiration from the
RC object class so we're gonna grab
pretty much you know for now I'll grab
all the fields and we'll kind of just go
through them and see what we can see
what we can or we can pick us up so
containers I've obviously database right
name length it's gonna have a name and
an A and a name length that's kind of a
given and then it's gonna have instead
of this field count that we've got here
we're actually going to have a count of
objects right now the other thing we
have to decide is whether or not we want
to store arrays inside objects I mean
I'm not sure if I touched on this last
time oh no ok we are storing arrays
inside objects yeah all right just
wanted to make sure that that was uh
that was in there so really all we need
is an object count so we don't need any
of this anymore
right so we have our C object objects
and then we have an object count all
right let's calculate a size as well so
this will be one - okay fine the last
thing that I really want to do though is
make sure that we are actually storing a
size it's something that we should have
been storing this whole time I wanted to
kind of add it as an optimization thing
but it's going to be much easier for us
to actually store the size instead of
having to read everything
so I think I'll stick this right over
here so private int size okay it's
actually going to be a field that is
legitimately in here now and everything
will get that eventually but we'll start
off with just database so we have when
we make the database we really just give
it a name and then I'll come into object
and I'll still that's that name thing
alright so now we've basically got a
name that we're setting set name name
right and then I'll also steel let's see
I mean I guess we'll still add field I
don't like the size thing that will
still add field for now where are we
I'll see database so our field becomes
our object
I'll see object object so objects dot
and object size is going to be object
get size and object count is going to
just be the size of the objects okay
cool so next up I guess we'll still
these two as well so we've got our get
size and we've got our get bytes and
then we'll kind of start writing this
stuff out so we've got the name and the
name the next thing that I do want to
write out is the actual size so this
will be point a right vice let's see
where we got here it's the destination
pointer and sighs okay and we'll add
this into pretty much a lattice into
every array and object and field
probably as well laughs you know ball
field doesn't need it but object and
array does okay cool
so then we'll write out we can get rid
of one of these will write out our
object counts and object objects
objects all right cool
there we go we're getting all the bytes
for everything and everything looks
pretty good right now so the size I just
want to go through this and make sure
that were kind of at a correct size here
so the size will basically be equal to
the one byte the short the name which we
don't know how big that is let's see how
we dealt with that here I think we did
that in I actually know I think setname
does that yes it does
okay good so we don't need that so we'll
have a name count there which is the
name length which is 2 we have the size
itself which we also have to include
we've got the object count which is true
and then we've got the amount of objects
which we kind of deal with later so
that's the size that that's what the
size is going to be set to initially we
will also make sure that we have a
similar thing and object I think we've
got 1 plus 1 plus 2 right 1 plus 2 plus
the thing plus 2 again and then plus 2
so we'll kind of stick in a plus 4 in
here just so that we are printing out
that size I'll move size to where it's
gonna be in the file structure and then
in get bytes I'm just going to make sure
that we write out the size just after
the name so sighs all right cool there
we go so now we're writing out the size
for the RC object and I guess the last
thing that we should do is do the same
thing for array so where is sighs I
guess we get the size just by doing this
so let's not do that the first thing we
should do is fix up a name so I'll
probably just copy set name from here
since that is the more complete one we
will have a just before we have the type
will have the size I don't know why I'm
making just private but anyway so we've
got that set up which is great let's
make sure this now returns size and then
I'll cut all of that and set it equal
here okay so we don't need to get the
other size anymore
we don't need name lengths so we've got
one one for the bite then two for the
show then the name which will be set in
set name size which is four then the
type and then the count and then the
actual data so the one of the things
that we are missing here is the actual
data so we don't know how big that is
yeah so when we actually do set the data
we can probably just do get data size
right so we create one from this data so
I think what we'll do is because the
data that data is somewhat variable I
mean we do like be the issue is that we
could all since all this is public
there's nothing to stop us from just
being like hey array I want to set the
data records or something else yeah
because the idea of sterilization is
really you don't want to change your
array once you make it like when I make
something like an RC array I shouldn't
be reassigning data or I shouldn't be
changing that it's fine for me to read
it but I don't necessarily want to be
able to modify it because it's it that's
not really how it's supposed to go right
if you want a new one who's making new
array however that is possible for us to
do here so it's kind of up to you how
you want to deal with this you could
basically leave the final piece of the
puzzle which is the you know the size
you could leave the the actual length of
this data array - whenever you retrieve
size and then you just add it on or
whatever you write out the size right I
could just write it along with the
actual size and that way I would have
the most current thing I'm gonna say
that I am actually going to enforce the
fact that once you do make an ask the
array that daughter was there yeah it
does not get modified because the idea
isn't isn't something like let's just
say that you have an array of random
numbers and then that for some reason is
in like an entity yeah when you create
the entity I'm not gonna make an RC
erase right away and then link it to
that like array of data that I have and
then later that same RC array will be
written out
a file or something that's not the way
that that works right what happens is
when I actually decide that hey I want
to now ride out to a file that's when I
create the RCRA with the data I want to
write out and I write it out right it's
not something that you create at object
initialization it's what you create when
you actually serialize the data and
that's something that probably should be
explained with comments and Javadoc and
whatever but that's the way that works
so because of that it's really important
to make sure that when we do something
like also get data size when we do
actually do this so we set the data here
and we return the array I'm just
thinking a good place for us probably is
we might have something like an in in
this method or something which I'm going
to well I'm not gonna call it in it
because it the only thing it's going to
do is update size so I'll say update
size right and then what that will do is
if we scroll up to the top here we'll
have a private avoid update size that
will just simply say size plus equals
get data size okay
that's really all I wanted to do again I
could you know it is one line I don't
have to make a method out of it but I
will anyway so update size the other
thing we need to make sure is that that
it is obviously being called from a
static instance so I'll just do that
alright so now we should have an
up-to-date size
and an outsize what they should get
printed out all right awesome so back in
our seed database which is the focus of
today's video we now have a size
hopefully that is actually correct
right and again we'll have to verify
this because I'm not even sure if I see
object probably does this we do have
size here but in terms of this stuff
course that wouldn't really I mean we do
actually I do we do append array size
and stuff and we are printing and
actually everything should be correct so
we'll double-check this in our testing
but I think that I think that we've got
all the functionality we need here okay
cool so where were we with databases so
we got data basically the name length
everything looks pretty good here I've
got our collection of objects that we
can and and they'll update everything so
I suppose equals order to get size good
everything was pretty good to me
and we were actually printing out
everything as well so we should be more
or less complete okay now again we don't
like optimization wise yes it would be a
great idea to have some kind of table
that shows us that shows us you know the
index basically into this database of
where each object is actually located
because if I have one an object called I
don't know something like you know
entity and this database happens to
contain a thousand objects I'm gonna
have to loop through the whole thing not
through every book and not not through
every byte but through every object to
find where that entity actually is right
instead of that I could just have a
table that showed me the byte offset of
the objects so I can just read that
straight away and that would be very
very fast it would be much faster than
the current system but that's like an
optimization thing that we will talk
about later okay
so there we have it there we have a
hopefully fully working serialization
system nothing to do with D
serialization yet but we should
able to sterilize daughter out pretty
well so let's talk about how we can do
this what we have to do now is create an
RC database we'll call this our database
I'll call this something like I'll just
call this database and one thing that I
quickly wanted to mention as well is
that we should probably have let's know
if we do this anyway we should have a
header which because this is like we
basically only contain one database per
file so what we should have is some kind
of header that says something like RC DB
or something rain cloud database that
just kind of makes sure that um the work
to correct now this should be a byte
array of course okay and that that just
kind of gives us you know that's just
there so that we know oh hey we're
reading a rain cloud database file okay
just to just it's it's almost like some
kind of like an initial validation right
it's just to it we can be like okay we
are indeed reading the right file
someone hasn't dropped in a file that is
in the incorrect format okay
very small header of course we only got
four bytes here but that is enough for
us to really identify what's going on
here so we'll say we'll write by its
destination pointer and of course ahead
of being the bytes that we're going to
write okay cool
so we've got the database we're going to
also I guess create the array where an
array we filled we create an object
called entity and let's just say let's
just add that to the database right now
so we'll say database and object object
and then of course here we'll use
database dog gets eyes and database to
get by its stream and we'll write that
into our tests RC d RC database or I'll
see DB file so let's just run this see
if we don't crash it doesn't look like
we did I want to quickly open x HX d I
just want to quickly see if I can open
so I can open up the folder here okay so
now we've got the test on our CD file
that I just opened up in this viewer
that's the new one you can see that
immediately we can see that we do indeed
start with our CD B as our header which
is fantastic let's go through this and
make sure it's all correct and we'll do
a few tests here just to make sure that
we are done because this is actually all
we need to do for civilization right so
the simulation series is kind of over
after this isn't it
the deesser ization series will start
next but now I'll probably keep it I'll
probably still call this the
resurrection serum I'm gonna make a new
series called T sterilization but anyway
this is like the last video so it's
quite kind of exciting as long as this
works of course so continue to type data
base that's four we know that because
four is right over here then what do we
have back to that is the name length
which is short so it looks like the name
is eight characters long and then we've
got the actual name now it doesn't look
like we do though did we print it out
the size before the name or something
cuz we do have it looks like an entire
like intz worth of stuff let's let's
just
I probably print it out yeah so sighs
whoops sighs should be sighs should be
off to name all right let's try that
again print all right this is looking
better so there's that short that's the
name then we have the actual name which
we know is eight characters so here it
is databases database eight bytes then
we have the I guess the size gets
printed out which is this number here
and then we have the object count which
is a short so it says that we've got one
object this is the size of the entire
database by the way right so this should
actually be the file size in bytes right
and I guess we can probably verify that
as well let me just open up this thing
in Windows Explorer so that I can kind
of where we are all right where are we
works
is Asian all right here we go so test I
see they actually got a large file it's
two hundred thousand seventy four bytes
okay
so let's get a calculator up I actually
don't have one
let's get a calculator up for reals
and/or actually a hex to decimal
converter windows calculator has that
unfortunately my one isn't working
around out because of Windows 10 loads
but anyway there's number we want to
convert so it looks like it's 3-0 d8 a
convert that and as you can see we
should get two hundred thousand and 74
right and that is indeed as we just saw
the file size two hundred thousand 74
all right fantastic
so that just verifies that that is
indeed working next up we have the
object count another thing you can do by
the way is if if you get this this this
number here which says what your file
size is you can actually verify that
that is indeed the size of the file that
you have okay this is especially useful
for files typically in typically in a
network scenario you might split up
these kind of binary streams usually you
will wait until you get all of them back
there first so for example if we were
sending this over TCP and we split this
up into ten packets or something we
would get the ten packets first
reconstructed data and then we take a
look at this and then this size for
example could be used to verify that we
did indeed get the packets
no one modified them or at least that in
modify the size and everything looks
pretty good now another thing we could
do in terms of security if you're
worried about someone modifying your
file obviously checking the size is one
thing you can do and it's a very quick
and easy thing you can do just to make
sure that you are still the same size
which means that no one's added or
removed bytes certainly also means that
you didn't lose half the file right
because you might have accidentally
interrupted a while it was being written
out of the game crashed while it was
writing and then this way you can just
verify that hey this is the correct file
this is what I
affected but if you're more concerned
about security and people modifying your
file you could of course generate a hash
of the file and then you can compare
that hash to you know running the hash
through all these bytes and seeing if
that map matches whatever hash is
actually in the the format of course
people could still modify that to match
the new one or whatever like that could
be done technically but yeah just make
sure you don't run the hash through the
hash because that's not gonna work
anyway because you don't know the hash
yet when you're on the initial test
anyway all that aside that is that's the
file size there which is very useful for
us we know that we have one object
that's our object count we then have the
beginning of the objects right so we
have one object and we know that it
starts on this next byte so let's go
into our CI objection see what we got
here so we have a container type of
object which is what the three is and
everything else actually we know is
correct already because we looked at the
last time we've got the where are we
I'll see object-- here we go I know the
name length which is six characters
that's the name and then we've got you
know all that other stuff you can see
we've got integer random numbers
whatever so that's that's quite a big
example because we've got all of that
stuff here we've got the entire random
numbers thing but let's try out another
field okay and I'll kind of I just won't
actually add the array this time so
we'll call this like position right and
then I'll say this is we have two
integers here maybe we have X the x
position so X pause I'll say is like
let's make this the reason I'm making
these integers so that we can actually
read them if I make it floats it's gonna
be very difficult for us to read the
memory we'll have to convert it so
that's one mile Bharatha brother roaming
data right now but I should say this is
like two and then so that's position X
and then position Y which will be Y
pause we can maybe set to like 30 or 43
we'll add those two fields just to make
sure the multiple fields work fine
let's just make them shorts just for fun
just to mix up the file type what's
wrong with that
really why do you not know them you're
short I guess because it would be
ambiguous anyway we've got the shorts
now and we've added them so we should be
correct as long as we don't add that
array which we didn't let's run that oh
we got crash that's exciting
why don't we get a crash I didn't know
that rain oh I didn't okay so this is
good so we've got how many fields three
fields
I don't know hang on it Oh the object
has three fields yeah so we got at one
object three fields good so why did that
crash let's see field count is three
good that's good
obviously it's around I had bound so we
didn't allocate enough space but why did
we not allocate enough space what point
was pointer up to 61 and the destination
has a size of wish you could easily see
of 60 okay so 69 is this size we are
currently up to 61 I guess when we tried
to ride this it increase to 70 and
that's what made it crash okay cool so
we know why it crashed which object will
be up to this is the bad thing about for
each lift I don't know where I'm up to I
guess I could read the object and see
what we have your name is that which I
mean that's the first one isn't it
alright so after an embarrassingly long
time I discovered that my size for my
daughter base was wrong because I added
this header but I didn't bother actually
writing that size in okay so this can
really be something like head a dot
length because
it's totally static and everything but
there we go so that's fun
don't forget to write that out and if
we'd run it now yeah we can say we get
no errors which is correct sir
that was uh yeah good times anyway now
that we've got a bit of a smaller thing
that we can look at it might be a lot
easier to see so we have the RC DB we've
got that that's the header right then
we've got so I guess it just worked for
the other thing that was odd wasn't it
because it did work for maybe I added
this now I'm not sure because it did
work for when I didn't have the fields
so that's weird
I had the array it totally worked
spooky anyway um I don't know why that
is a lot to investigate that maybe
there's extra room in our array or
something like that that I didn't see
but it looks pretty okay yeah very odd
alright anyway so then we've got four
which means it's a database then we've
got the the size of the name which is
eight bytes then we've got an integer or
something what is that even where are we
we've got the size yes that's it that's
the file size and bytes we never filed
49 bytes and then we've got the fact
that this is a field of type 3 and the
name is six characters it's called
entity and it's set to 34 well not
really 34 but 34 and um what is empty as
an object okay I've got object and we've
got the size of the objects or thirty
four bytes for the object we know that
we have three fields in it the first
thing in the field okay so where was the
object because I thought that was
objects three okay one right
so this was one object right and that's
the type that was objects okay cool so
one object the the type is seven which
means it's a double and that's wrong I
must be looking the wrong thing was
object oh sorry that's name length
integer is the name for is the type
which is integer and then we have what's
next we have eight which is the actual
integer then we have another field it's
the name is four characters exposition
and it's set to two and then we have yes
is that two which is this here all right
what's that extra character there I'm
being very meticulous with my testing
here that's got to be the type riot
which we set is short so yes - okay good
that's the value which we put in which
is here - and then we have another one
for for the name there's the name
there's the type there's the data which
is this kind of plus sign to be which is
43 and then we've got just two null
characters that does not seem right why
do we have two null characters at the
end we shouldn't have any I believe as
soon as that object ends away we're done
oh we have a ray count do we really put
that after the fields I guess we do okay
we've got a short for a right count
which is the two bytes here that we say
that are both zero which means we have
no arise all right cool
so that is it that is the end of
basically the Civilization series we now
have the ability to store as any kind of
daughter out
we have no idea how to read it yet
that's gonna we're gonna begin that
journey next episode but thank you guys
for watching and I'll see you next time
if you enjoyed this video please hit the
like button and have a nice day goodbye